وبالعوده الى التطورات الهجمات المتزايده
داخل روسيا قالت مجموعه ما يعرف بفيلق
حريه روسيا التي تتالف من روس يقاتلون مع
القوات الاوكرانيه قالت انها تقاتل قوات
الرئيس بوتين عند مشارف قريه تقع داخل
الحدود الغربيه لروسيا وذلك بعد يوم فقط
من اعلان موسكو صدى الثلاث هجمات على
الحدود هذه الهجمات جاءت في اعقاب توغل
كبير في منطقه
بلغاريتا غربي روسيا يومي الثاني والعشرين
والثالث والعشرين من شهر مايو وزياده
القصف عبر الحدود في الاسابيع القليله
الماضيه
فيلق حريه روسيا يهدف الى انشاء منطقه
منزوعه السلاح على طول الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وذلك لمنع المدفعيه الروسيه من
اطلاق النار على اوكرانيا من الاراضي
الروسيه كما يسم
هذا الفيلق قاتل الى جانب القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وذلك في مدينه دومباس اثناء
هجوم شرقي اوكرانيا وتفيد مصادر يقاتل بعض
من افراده في باخمت
وينظر اليهم على انهم جزء من المتطوعين
الدوليين الاوسع في القوات الاوكرانيه
طبعا لا تتوفر معلومات دقيقه ومن جهه
مستقله عن فيلق حريه روسيا الذي يقاتل الى
جانب القوات الاوكرانيه ضد سلطات موسكو
وما هو متاح مصدره اما الدعايه الخاصه
بالفيلق او المخابرات الاوكرانيه ويبقى
عددهم سريا للغايه ولا يمكن الوصول الى
مواقعهم لنرى ماذا نعرف استنادا للمعلومات
المتداوله يتكون الفيلق من مجموعه شبه
عسكريه روسيه لكنها تتخذ من اوكرانيا مقرا
لها تعارض حكومه الرئيس فلانديمير
كذلك
تشكل هذا الفيلق في مارس 2022 ويقال انه
جزء من الفيلق الدولي للدفاع الاقليمي عن
اوكرانيا شعاره
يتمثل او يمثل بالاحرى قبضه تحمل
عبارتي روسيا وحريه ويستخدم العلم الابيض
والازرق والابيض الذي يراه جزء من
المعارضه الروسيه على انه علم روسيا الحره
يتالف هذا الفيلق فيلق حريه روسيا من
منشقين عن القوات الروسيه باضافه الى
متطوعين روس اخرين هجر بعضهم الى اوكرانيا
عقب نشوب الحرب
خلال مقابله في يناير الماضي قلل المتحدث
باسم المنظمه الذي يطلق على نفسه اسم قيصر
قال ان الفيلق يضم مئات المتطوعين الروس
وقد اشارت تقارير اعلاميه الى خضوع
المقاتلين في الفيلق لمقابلات واختبارات
نفسيه وحتى لجهاز كشف الكذب تحسبا لاي
محاوله اختراق